but at this point yesterday we had Rick
Carlisle of the Dallas Mavericks on the
show he is the president of the NB a
Coaches Association NBC a National
Basketball Coaches Association and he
mentioned how within hours after the
murder of George Floyd on the streets of
Minneapolis
he said that all 30 NBA head coaches got
together on a zoom and had a
conversation about what that was all
about and what next and what they could
all do together and he said that they
were leading of trying to lead the way
and he was taking the lead of the head
coach of the Atlanta Hawks Lloyd Pierce
who was kind enough to join me right
here at the top of this hour on this day
of the Rich Eisen show how are you coach
appreciate you taking the time so walk
me through what Rick Carla rick carlisle
was kind of walking me through yesterday
about that 30 wide if you will all NBA
head coaches zoom what she said was
within the hours of what everybody saw
and was horrified by on the streets of
Minneapolis coach yeah you know I
reached out to coach Carlisle and David
Vogel you know they were on the they're
in charge of the NB C a and I just said
listen we meet on everything having to
do with coach related issues our 401ks
the direction of the funding for the
coaches association contracts things of
that nature things that are important to
us and and there's not a bigger issue
that was important to me what we're
saying with regard Safran Americans and
police brutality and just the the
entirety of what's going on in our
country and I just felt you know we have
to Hue too big of a platform and we are
united already as an association of
coaches that we have to discuss this
because we lead a league of
african-american men but I'm
african-american men and we lead a
league that these men have to deal with
these issues and for us to be leaders we
need to be educated and we need to do it
in a way where you were united on that
education and
laughs when using our platform to do
that so what where does everything what
was that conversation like can you share
it was easy I said Rick I'm I can't
couple in your show but I used some
words yes I said I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm vulnerable right now
I'm angered I'm vulnerable I'm an
african-american coach I'm a young
african-american coach I have a young
african-american team in terms of the
the players that we have and and and
it's going to be hard for me to lead
knowing that I'm still in the same way
that some of them may be feeling and we
have to discuss this as coaches we can't
just walk in and say we can't wait for
the season to start and we haven't
addressed a real live issue that's going
on in our country and so I expressed
that I told them we have to do something
and that's the point of a union of a
kind of a Coaches Association it's to
address matter that that are important
and this is important so what was the
conversation like when you all got on
the zoom you know they gave me the
platform to speak and I spoke freely and
I spoke openly and I spoke passionately
about systemic racism blatant racism and
the fact that we need to do something
and you know from the response we had
every coach there and there was dialogue
with every coach after but the response
was simple thank you this is needed what
can we do and and I truly mean mean that
when I say all 30 coaches were
passionate they were energized they were
they've been motivated and they still
are to use their platform in their
cities to address racism to talk about
the issue we've we've never confronted
in the history of our country and to try
and build up our communities through
this education and our coaches I'll tell
you what our coaches are are phenomenal
right now with their attendance with
their attention with the email change
that we have going on with the text
messages that we have going on sharing
articles sharing information having
dialogue reaching out to a community
relations team it's been been enjoyable
to be a part of but we know we have a
lot of work to do
well you're annoyed Pierce Atlanta Hawks
head
joining me here on the Richardson show
and I'm appreciative of you joining and
you know I look forward to having you on
on subjects about the sport itself which
I'll get to in a second but your
Instagram post where it was just a shot
of your face close up I want to give you
the floor on what that was and calling
people's attention to it to check out on
your Instagram account and and and allow
you to sort of walk us through why you
posted it what was going through your
mind and what's going through it now I
posted it because I think sometimes
people feel things more when it's closer
to you when it's closer to your heart
when you have a connection you know you
feel the death of a person when it's a
friend the family friend someone that
you knew it attacks you emotionally and
so I'm a head coach and I just wanted to
know my followers or people that know me
as a head coach I wanted them to know
that I'm also a blackness and for 44
years I've been a black man you know and
if you change the words if you don't
know that it's coach Pearce and you
realize that I've been affected by this
this tragedy that George Floyd has
experienced and his family has
experienced it can happen to me it
almost will happen to me in some form or
fashion whether it's me directly someone
I'm related to or someone that I know
and a lot of times I think we move on
because it doesn't hit us and I just
wanted it to hit everybody the way it's
hitting me
and so if i zoom in you just know it's a
black man you zoom out and you say oh my
goodness I didn't realize it was Coach
Pierce it shouldn't matter shouldn't
matter who it is it shouldn't happen any
african-american person it shouldn't
happen in any person shouldn't happen
definitely shouldn't have any black
people because of the color of their
skin and that's what's happening right
now
Lloyd Pierce Hawks head coach here on
the Rich Eisen show prior to your tenure
with the Hawks you spent a few years as
an assistant LeBron James on that team
in Cleveland I'm assuming you saw like
the rest of us that LeBron James and
several other African American stars and
athletes and entertainers are going to
get together and they have
formed something called more than a vote
aimed at inspiring African Americans to
register and cast a ballot in November I
assume you were part as a lot of
assumptions here of what we saw this
past week in the state of Georgia and
there is a photograph I guess of you and
your your your your your wife and so
there you are many people across this
country are terming what was going down
in the state of Georgia as purposeful
disenfranchisement I'm wondering where
you stand on on this subject and whether
you're gonna bring your your platform to
what LeBron is starting right now just a
just cinema text-message less than an
hour ago the saying that I'm all in our
organization we're having discussions
about what we can do you know I live I
live in the suburbs
I live in Brookhaven which is right next
to Buckhead which is popular in Atlanta
it's it's it's it's still in metro
Atlanta but I'm in DeKalb County and my
voting process was 20 minutes but when
you get into the heart of the city where
it's you know South Atlanta Fulton
County where it is lower income it is
some areas are african-american dominant
it's the same thing I witnessed this
when I first got here we had the issue
with with the governor's race and voter
suppression occurred then the voter
suppression occurred here at 7 a.m.
which was amazing like they just it was
blatant that there was going to be
issued in Polk County and then many
other counties in the state of Georgia
but it was it's voter suppression at its
finest it is purposeful we can't have
these same issues I love what LeBron and
the other athletes are doing to address
it and partner with the local
organizations to get registration going
get education going and get people to
the polls but you know it enoughenough
it's about as blatant in this purposeful
as it can be in it and it's sad that
it's here in our state but but it's
definitely by design in it and it's a
frustrating frustrating chain of events
that have occurred for many years in the
state of Georgia yes and
apparently one of the teammates if you
will for LeBron on more than a vote is
Trey young who you know very very well
as you're trying to have his career
blossom even more amazingly already and
he was vocal if I'm not mistaken active
in some of the protesting that went down
yeah out in out in norm in his hometown
he he spoke of doing that with the
family member and and really just doing
something that even you know never done
before it's out of his comfort zone but
having the courage and the bravery to do
it here you see them again joining
forces with the other athletes represent
city of Atlanta and voter suppression
issues that we have you know you talk
about young players and you talk about
all our young players and couldn't be
more proud of our guys our players you
see and JJ reddick speak out Kyle Korver
speak out LeBron James speak out Trey
young speak out Donovan Mitchell speak
out you see in Jalen Brown's ride
fifteen hours to get to Atlanta to
protest and Malcolm Brogdon
proud of our guys proud of our league
proud of our guys really stepped into
the forefront and it's our job now as
coaches yes they were supposed to leave
you've got to support them and encourage
them this is going to help for me
personally Trey's growth is development
to use his voice to use this platform
purposely yeah I think this does you
need to work on his horse game a little
bit if I recall that a few weeks ago he
definitely got the poor draw he got he
got the poor draw mr. Bicks ID man
that's a tough that's a tough draw but I
do I do love his game
I do love Trey's game no doubt about it
he's one of the more dynamic players in
this league and exciting players in this
league I mean when when the Hawks do get
back out there coach what is you know
defense obviously has been a subject of
conversation as you know in your world
over the last 24 hours your bailiwick if
you will from your time with
Philadelphia where do you stand on that
subject right here Lloyd bringing that
seriousness my to me it's mindset you
know I think when we have that
commitment that we have that that we
mentality you know you see in the last
dance and
really educational to watch that Michael
Jordan shifting and really adopting this
weed mentality and getting guys rallying
cuz guys trust me kids guys you know
when we're that way we have the mindset
to be that way and we have the mindset
that we're no longer player development
and junk youth isn't an excuse all of
the things are going to come together
offense needs to improve our defense
needs to improve our approach needs to
improve and so it's our mindset we're
going to shift our mindset we're gonna
we're going to work on that and we're
going to do it together and I look
forward to our group next year I love
how you mentioned the last dance like
that coach because I had again just I
guess to bring a full circle here with
rick carlisle because he was on the
bench as an assistant for larry bird and
those pacer teams that were prominently
displayed in the last couple episodes of
the last dance as well as a member of
the knicks
who had to deal with jordan at the end
of the 80s as he was ascending to his
greatness i asked him what he learned
from it and he kind of laughed he talked
about how one thing phil jackson how
phil he gained even more respect for
fulfill for what jackson had to weave
together and put everything any other
and then he also talked about the
mindset and how tape today's players
need to heed I guess the mindset about
being about the Rings would you agree
with that plant fortunate that we got we
got away from that I don't know you know
in sport the ultimate is winning it's
all about you know the journey and
getting through to get that last that
last victory and you know when we got
away from that I don't know I don't know
who or how but you know that's important
I think we're all gonna have accolades
we're all gonna have success on sport in
our own individual ways me being a head
coach wow that's great I want to win I
want to be known as a guy that was able
to turn this program around it became a
championship contender for many years
and get that victory here for the city
of Atlanta and so you know that's the
mindset our league has to adopt and our
players and we're going to do it
individually with our own teams but
that's it there's nothing else we can
talk about everything
it's about winning and how do we get to
doing it together that's the we
mentality that we have to have I enjoy
the journey I enjoy the process we're
going to we're going to focus on that
the entire time but the end game is
getting that ring yeah I guess you know
maybe you won't have to deal like Phil
did with the player wanting to go to
Vegas in the middle of the year or WWE
in the middle of a championship it's it
is amazing if a guy needs that break and
he's that that much of a contributor you
know I gotta adjust any works of them if
someone needs that trip to Miami for the
weekend yeah we'll have to make do
somebody else I guess so hey Lloyd I
appreciate the time let's continue let's
continue talking I really appreciated
this conversation and you know we now
are showing you your Instagram post of
your face and what it really again means
is is truly remarkable and I'm glad that
we brought you on the show too to bring
this to everybody's attention if they
needed it anymore and I'd love to
continue you being on this show as a
platform dialog and obviously as the
Hawks begin to get back in action and
win some games yeah I appreciate that
not to told everyone that I've spoken to
you know you wanting to have me on is
even more important to keep this
conversation going and keep this
dialogue going so I appreciate you for
that and my pleasure let's do it again
thanks coach that's Thank You Lloyd
Pearce the head coach of the Atlanta
Hawks you're on the Rich Eisen show